yes yes
[Music]
clearly His Last Stand since he was
ousted in a constitutional vote of
narcotic prevention back in April Imran
Khan's position on elections is that he
was ousted by a political and Military
establishment
that concluded with the foreign power
the U.S allegedly to have them ousted
none of that has been proved Imran Khan
claims that this government is a
legitimate and the only way to reclaim
legitimacy and the only way to make a
fresh start is to go to the people with
a fresh mandate
[Music]
so that's the case where he was
disqualified from his current seat in
Parliament which does not mean that he
can't contest Journal lessons this
particular love March comes at a very
significant time the Army Chief a new
Army Chief will be appointed in late
November that's a very significant
appointment Iran Khan has very clearly
said in his speeches that he doesn't
think that current political correlation
government has a moral standing to a
point to the current Army chief
[Music]
Islamabad has been under a kind of siege
for a month since imman Khan announced
that he would be holding a long march at
some point in time to get people behind
him he has a very loyal support and base
and that support her base uh completely
buys into his propaganda into his
um his victim of narrative and and
because they see this as His Last Stand
they would absolutely support him
foreign
[Music]